looked at human beings from 3,000 years
ago to human beings of today we're
moving in a general direction of a much
more positive culture great like is does
to me to me it does to a sysm is
negative can't be depleted but don't you
think it can be shunned out of society
slowly but surely if people realizes
repercussions questions but then you're
operating from a fear that doesn't mean
that you're not racist because you're
afraid to say it no but people realize
that you know it hurts people's feelings
and it causes all sorts of issues and no
human beings especially when they're in
and I've learned this whole time when
they're in a spot where they're
fundamentally unhappy it's very easy for
them to you know lash out and so if you
find someone who's just miserable right
who doesn't you know have I don't know
the career the girl whatever it is that
person is much more likely to say
something that's patriotic and that's
just that's the human condition like
you're not happy so you lash out at
someone else I agree with you but don't
you think that human beings in general
are less racist today certainly less
racist publicly in America than 1950 oh
my gosh yes no question - past 68 years
ago if we go back sixty-eight years ago
the world has changed for the better
oh like 100 percent in terms of like the
social project progress that we've made
especially in America do you think that
68 years from now we could at least come
very close to eradicating racism that's
a very good question so if you're
talking about just America yes
well let's just go with America because
it's just right now because I don't know
what the [ __ ] going on China yeah you
know wherever that's why I say like go
away change it up because then they'll
say Americans are racist towards Muslims
right when you say that you're gonna do
the Muslim the Muslim banned from
certain countries and that's also
considered like racism and not just like
you know national security right so
everything sort of becomes racism so the
problem with racism is nobody knows it
means anymore well everything's racist
you can you could the Starbucks
situation which to me was not right
it was racist is that racism the
Starbucks wasn't race it you don't think
that was racist no so you think if those
were white dudes hanging out in
Starbucks not buying anything just
sitting down mind their own business
that they would've got [ __ ] with with
the same exact let's splits plaintiff
picture so first off I live in
Philadelphia I'm not kidding I wonder if
sometimes when I'm there I'm like I
wonder if any white people live here
like Philadelphia is like it's 44% black
not just excluding Hispanic 44% black
it's unbelievable everyone who works in
my build everyone's black it's like the
weirdest thing I'm like this is a very
black city right it's a bizarre City to
be racist outright racist in like you're
dealing with by people all day so you
remove that and then you think to me and
I've seen this happen tons of times
is it possible right that this guy was
just on like a power guy power trips
happen I've seen it happen at the most
bizarre places and I'm like all right
like I the airport the other day like
this woman gave me absolute hell that's
yes I mean it was like I came recap
today it was just absolute hell I could
have walked away and said she was racist
and she randomly selected my bag 22
times to go through and made me go
through and miss my flight right or she
was having a bad day and she was power
tripping you know and then people have
these little positions it's like that
that movie where they go door man you
know like and they have these little
positions like the manager of Starbucks
and and you're having an off day and
these two kids that could have easily
said I'll buy a cookie right like common
decency by the way even for me if I go
use the bathroom at Starbucks
I'll just freakin buy a cookie or a
little like juice box or water just
something that makes me feel alright
it's a little more civilized if I just
buy something even though I'm just here
to use the bathroom like so I'm both of
you gotta pee real bad in the line you
go and then i-i'll probably sprint to
the bathroom and then buy something
afterwards I do that this is like a
natural thing I like it because of these
guys you could just now rich culture
insane like my cousin who's half-mexican
on black had to go through this training
and she works for Starbucks it's like
it's to me it's just insane it's like is
it possible that this guy was
power-tripping these kids for being like
you know they could have just bought
something and it could have been
resolved but you have two people that
are being stubborn and and taking it to
as far as possible you know talk about a
call monitor like you know these are the
rules and it just got too far well
perspective that is possible but it's
also possible that they were racially
selected yeah
that someone was racist I looked at them
and they said these guys are black yeah
we don't want them sitting around here
not buying anything
no weren't they just waiting for their
friend too the whole thing didn't make
how long were they sitting there because
I want to say 45 minutes but that's like
until the cops got there like there
probably weren't I mean how long does it
take to get the cops to come in Philly
wait sorry I'm just like if you were
sitting there I feel like no I don't
know I've never called the cops I'm
feeling but I do know that like Philly
is it's just a very it's a very black
city yeah it's a very black city you
know I was there with Dave Rubin and
joint Peterson Peterson yeah you know I
opened for them and it's just it's a
womb you stand up yeah I should do stand
up I'd be good at it I'm funny come out
tonight oh yeah I'll get you up I'll do
it
oh we know I can't I have a I'm going to
Wyoming right after this yeah you have
any ideas of what you were talking about
if you went on stage I don't like I
would be really funny though I'm like
randomly really funny randomly I'm good
at voices not when people pay no I would
be really good like I'm really good
voices like really good like I I'm not
going to believe that most people think
they would do really good stand-up but I
talk [ __ ] yeah I can see that it's gonna
be just like I'm not funny anymore
it seems I probably would be like a
drinker if I was onstage I feel like I
would be like that like stereotypical
comedian that just gets completely
sloshed and goes outside just to try to
loosen up the ABS yeah I think it's a
really hard thing to try it to be funny
in front of like a sold-out room I think
it's important to be objective and I
think it's important to to look at
something for what it really is and I
think it's highly possible that that
Starbucks thing was racist I see I think
is just as yeah it's just a great
culture it's here we are it's got it's
got to be racist it's like yes did the
chances I'm just telling you've like so
a lot of black people that come in I
work from the Starbucks I'm writing a
book I work from Starbucks all over
Philadelphia that's like what I do right
and it's it's just there's I don't know
if there's any white people in
Philadelphia I'm constantly I did a show
there recently where what what area of
town were you man was in the tower
theater that's
inside your thing but they probably
commuted know that [ __ ] yeah they did
yeah it's all black people chores balls
yeah it's a bizarre place thank you yeah
it's rough it's really rough and after
people don't understand I'm like dude
like it's a weird place to come to if
you're racist just so it's like really
hard to be racist and Philadelphia
because everyone's black like it's like
we went to the movies once and we saw
Planet of the Apes actually ironically
in a really black neighborhood and then
we were it was I was there for the UFC
and it was me again my friend Tommy from
Connecticut and we were looking for
somewhere to go and we went to this uber
black neighborhood and it was a [ __ ]
blast he's right it was hilarious right
because I never I never go to all-black
movie theater they were yelling [ __ ] the
screen I mean it became like it was
there was the audience that was
entertaining and there was a movie at
air Talese there's one scene in the
movie where the you know the plan of the
apes cut what was the guy's name Caesar
got mad is like oh you [ __ ] up
barbequed we were high out of our mind
so the whole thing was like extra
hilarious black hole this is the thing
it's in so funny because so much of what
I do is inspired by this is just like
people like this I guess presentation of
black people in the media it actually
gets me mad because to me and I could be
biased I think black people are like the
most like funny like we're so funny so
endearing like when I'm around my
cousins like I do there's not a better
time that I can have when I'm around my
family
we're not easily offended right we're
constant making fun of each other making
fun of other people like there's no one
meaner a lot of people were portrayed
like victims like everything upsets us
like we're just we feel so oppressed and
I'm like this is not like the the black
community that I grew up in in my family
and it's also not the the black
community looks like who we celebrate
like I was watching was it Chris Rock
stand up bigger and blacker I watched
that like from 1994 classic like it is
like the stuff that he said he could
never say today just like it's up that
is black culture if he went there on
every single race every single culture
made fun of everybody and it was
beautiful it was perfection it was a
sold-out Apollo Theater he comes out in
the first thing he says it's like ray
she was like oh
people in the back today you know what I
mean and everyone gets up and starts
cheering and they starts making fun of
lock you up about things that we need to
fix right he's using like it's he's
being funny but he's also saying stuff
that's real talking about that baby mama
culture and the difference between like
the white community he starts she's
talking about school shootings and it
just like maybe it was Columbine that
just happened and he starts talking
about that and nobody was sensitive
nobody nobody in the audience was going
the ad all right well